foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
now guys I'm going to show you how you
can find food using only basic tools
that you might find in your pockets uh
yeah I'd like to order for delivery
oh it also I ain't got a coupon for a
free sweet and sour chicken oh there's
one right there he's coming towards you
babe
what happened
fell in the water
oh
hey Tommy see that that airplane with
the bicycle tires and stuff we could
build one of those and fly it around and
go fishing
would you like to build one of those
airplanes
yeah why don't you go ask your mom if we
can go build one
no no no
no
no
all right Becca give the bar to go
hold up
a workout
[Music]
we're reviewing the cheapest and most
expensive baby on amazon.com I want to
do a special thanks for this video
sponsor the brat grabber 2000.
all right that's the last of the
sunscreen
all right guys it's bedtime happy
birthday I told you I wouldn't forget
it's the new Daiwa and gas BR spinning
reel
time to clean up Mom
what did you say to your mother
no I got you now
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
Nathan are you a bumblebee yeah
yeah
stinger
you know I know how to do a tornado okay
you know how to do a tornado kick
me I'm gonna kick your butt that
escalated quickly wait a minute
is that your diaper yeah oh wait a
minute you're naked Okay Nathan's going
full nudist on us
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
was throwing up
poor little guy I told him not to lick
the handrail
foreign
don't eat the meat I thought you had
grown up past that
oh that kid loves to eat my bait
go oh
and he's released what are you doing I
was meant fogging
[Music]
there you go there you go Dad
congratulations look at that you dropped
a sick beat here stand there and I'll
take your picture okay okay Nathan hold
still no no don't climb on the railing
just just hold still just just stand by
your brother and just hold still no okay
well close enough come on Tom get your
boots on we're going to get breakfast
there are your boots Put your boots on
boots boots
wait is that right there just put your
feet
it's like this every time he's using his
pencil he got in from the house to be a
unicorn
and occasionally stabs people
okay
look at the view
who's getting on me roll up the window
yeah
yeah
fishing without pants on that's that's
how you live life folks see this playing
behind us
that's the F-14 let me tell you a story
about a man named goose and a man named
Maverick
[Music]
and he died in his arms in the water and
that's when he began to question himself
but over Libya Maverick skills would be
necessary and that's when he would
finally shake the ghosts of Goose's
death
[Music]
yep
[Laughter]
oh hey look guys
I forgot I totally forgot we packed
Jacob keep going we only have 15 more
miles to go you're tired
do you know who else was tired
the Donner Party they were tired Luke
Tom and Nate here with the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and I'm going to show
you how to track
toddlers once you have the kids secured
in the bag you want us to date them with
some basic chloroforms
all right
works every time this one right here
decided it'd be funny to run away from
Mom and Dad and run around the chapel
screaming during the church service
Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and today we're hunting toddlers
[Music]
[Applause]
fat man in a little boat
started digging right there
oh hey it's pretty big
what is that
looks like some sort of note
oh
[Music]
[Music]
go shoot a child
all right guys you ready to go to the
dump
I'm gonna read and answer the best
questions and concerns for my internet
trolls IDK commented the sad part is
that you guys are actually watching this
thanks for the view and the comment IDK
I appreciate the support Finn C simply
commented with 23 thumbs down emojis
I responded with 45 thumbs up emojis
in your face Flynn
[Music]
Nathan are you making dirt angels
I'm getting the sand off I'm getting all
the standoff I'd like to introduce you
to our new adult co-host sir Mario
Franklin and Mr Godzilla hello
that's an excellent mustache you have
don't worry about that
[Laughter]
foreign
Jacob Jacob
why were you screaming all night
don't be saying that sorry sorry Tommy
don't worry Curtis a lot of people
missed their first eight shots You Gotta
Wear Your tinfoil hat so YouTube can't
read your thoughts and demonetize my
videos
it's true can you read my baby's
thoughts
yeah neither can the FBI
oh
go to bed oh Nathan you want to drink a
milk
too bad
go to bed you want a drink of milk too
remember Nathan remember Daddy loves you
very much now go to sleep Kodiak Island
is a little bit south of Anchorage it's
a big Island full of deer and salmon and
killer grizzly bears
and they like to attack Hunters when
they hear a gun go off they know that
someone shot a deer so they run over and
attack the Hunter and take his deer many
Hunters have been killed by grizzly
bears
roll around do you hear me roll around
on the ground
we are making the stinkiest the
raunchiest catfish bait ever and I'm
using my wife's blender now luckily
she's not home today otherwise she would
murder us for this but we've got some
fermented shaft guts and chicken livers
and wait do you hear that yeah
mom's home we're dead we gotta get out
of here
[Music]
all right gotta get out of here
[Music]
hey guys I'm home what's that smell
oh Luke Nathan where are you guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching